and then I Googled like Mark Manson
house because that's always like to tell
I'm like is someone like crushing it
because you can't really like it's hard
to get a mortgage for a 15 million
dollars unless you're actually raking it
in and it said like you know Mark Manson
sells Tribeca condo for 14 million
dollars and I'm like damn like I thought
book the book business was a bad
business he must have crushed it he must
be making millions
[Music]
my man Ryan holiday are you done I said
nice to talk to you
it's good to talk to you too
um so you you asked to come here and
I'll just because I just want to get out
of the way I want to give you the love
you asked to come on here because hey
we're homies and I love you yeah and
also because B you have a book coming
out
discipline is Destiny this is the new
one for the series uh yeah it came out
yesterday
oh and how's it going so far
really good really good it should be
significantly higher it's already
significantly higher than the last one
and then you're so I I know where the
numbers are but I'm waiting the one
thing you don't know until the end of
the second week is audiobook numbers and
uh where it may or may not land on the
bestseller list what do you think
there's the outcome of this one's going
to be
um we'll probably come in a bit above 40
000 copies the first week I would I
would venture to guess uh could be
higher if they keep trending this way so
because I have my own bookstore and I
did the sales through my own bookstore I
probably won't hit the Wall Street
journalist uh they've they uh they
skunked me last time and then the New
York Times list is let's say 50 50. all
of which my publisher is very concerned
about and I've decided that I don't care
about at all anymore because if you own
your own bookstore that means that and
you sell 20 000 copies do they not count
all twenty thousands in in the rankings
yeah so I mean just generally if you
sold 20 000 copies of a book through One
Bookstore they would find that to be
suspicious uh uh or or unrepresentative
and there's a chance it could get tossed
if you ever look at the at the best
seller list and you see like a little
they call it a dagger it's like a little
cross next to certain books that means
that there was a lot of bulk purchases
um or like suspicious activity so there
could be that
um but uh
the The Wall Street Journal or book scan
which is owned by Nielsen just flat out
told me they just don't include uh sales
from uh stores owned by the author
anymore uh which doesn't strike me as
that being a big enough category to have
a rule about but
um I guess it there's the potential for
fraud like I guess theoretically I could
have just you know inflated the numbers
or something so so there's a chance it
could get tossed but as I have gone on
as an author I've cared once you get it
once I feel like you have it and then
you also realize like kind of how
meaningless things are uh so I care a
lot less about
sort of the status or the recognition of
sales and I care a lot more about you
know did I sell as many copies as
possible
uh to as many people as possible right
um because the whole place for people to
read it does being on that list and when
you say the best seller list are you
meaning just the New York Times is that
considered like the list and just being
on that there's help sales
there's there's sort of three lists
there's New York Times which you
probably rank is number one Wall Street
Journal which you'd probably rank as
number two and then USA Today those are
the three uh what you have to hit one of
those three lists to be called the
national bestseller those are the three
National lists
um
there is I think people tell themselves
a story about how being on the list
helps them sell more copies but as
someone who buys a lot of books and
talks to a lot of people who buy a lot
of books I have never once heard of
someone buying a book because they saw
it on a list most people don't even know
where they would find such a list dude I
was reading um uh is it News Corp or I
forget the company the the it's Rupert
Murdock's company but he has two of them
I forget which one is uh that owns I
think penguin and they did this whole I
was reading their annual report and they
were doing this entire section on Mark
Manson and basically saying like this
has been like a breakthrough hit and
like this is uh you know the company's
like a 20 or 40 billion dollar company
and they're referencing Mark Manson I'm
like oh wow that's that must be a huge
book uh in order for them to like
discuss this in a six pages of a hundred
page document and then I Googled like
Mark Manson house because that's always
like to tell I'm like is someone like
crushing it because you can't really
like it's hard to get a mortgage for 15
million dollar house unless you're
actually raking it in and it said like
you know Mark Manson sells Tribeca condo
for 14 million dollars and I'm like damn
like I thought book the book business
was a bad business he must have crushed
it he must be making millions it's
actually a great business so the the
publishing industry I think is about a
40 billion dollar industry uh News Corp
owns harpercollins harpercollins
publishes uh Mark uh penguin random
house which is my publisher is the
biggest publisher in the world and they
are themselves let's look uh penguin
Random House I think they're owned by a
parent company I forget the parent
company they're owned by bertelsman or
something like that yeah yeah that's
right but
um here let's uh revenues their revenues
I bet I uh 4 billion Euro for for
penguin random house so it's a it's a
very big business
um uh and and always has been and there
are multi multiple multi-billion dollar
you know businesses inside that business
even even Ingram which is the
distributor that sells books to most
independent retail is like a seven or
eight billion dollar business but Mark's
probably sold I think um
I think uh subtle art of not giving a
sold like 10 or 15 million copies
and what do they cost 20 bucks
yeah so so if you think about like my
books I've sold 5 million copies if you
said 20 that's that's a hundred million
dollars in gross revenues right there
right now now obviously there's a lot of
middlemen even before it gets to the
publisher right the publisher is selling
the book at wholesale so right there uh
that's you know cuts it in half uh and
then you know it goes down but but there
are V if you think about uh how much a
book sells for and the quantities of
which successful authors sell a lot of
books that that number gets very very
high this is why JK Rowling is is a
billionaire right she's probably sold
100 200 million Harry Potter books not
including licensing and all the other
things you know uh different the the
different formats whether it's audio or
ebook or physical or hardcover even
hardcover and paperback is a big thing
like one of the I bet Mark for instance
said I I know Mark and he's amazing the
distinction the decision to put your
book in paperback is actually a
multi-million dollar decision for
authors and and most authors have never
even thought about this so for instance
on a hardcover book
um the the standard publishing contract
and pretty much everyone including the
authors that are uh household names are
on the same contract it's just this is
what it is is uh 15 on hardcover price
so uh an author makes you know 15 of 27
whether you as the customer get that
book for 17 on Amazon or for 27 at an
independent bookstore you're making the
same amount right your your royalty is
on MSRP but 15 of hardcover right a
paperback sells for about 10 to 15
dollars less than a hardcover right but
and your royalty is 12 and a half
percent so my my agent very early who
was in publishing he was like he was
like uh I will never let your books go
into paperback
um he's like you have to sell about as
third you have to sell a third more
books to make the same amount of money
that you've sold in hardcover and this
is why Tim ferriss's books are not
widely available in paperback good to
Great by Jim Collins which has sold tens
of you know probably 10 million copies
still in hardcover even though it's a 20
year old book so there's lots of little
decisions
so audible you make uh I think it's the
same as I I think Audible and ebook are
25 of list price so you make it it's a
higher royalty but on a lower price
point audiobooks are like 15 bucks or
nine bucks uh for for ebooks a lot of
times uh so so somewhere between two and
three bucks a book you make across
formats so if you're in hardcover ebook
and so you think Mark's book has sold
200 is I think did you say 200 million
in sales so no no 20. he's probably sold
20 million books oh sorry in gross
revenue
oh uh was it 20 million books times
hardcover price or you know it it
there's gonna be a a blend there of the
price the only the only thing that's
worth pointing out this isn't a
criticism it's a it's just a quirk of
the business Mark has sold a Mark's
books are very big internationally right
his books are big in Brazil his books
are big in India uh I I've experienced
the same thing but as soon as you start
like so as soon as you start selling
lots of copies internationally let's
just say you start seeing a lot less
money for those titles right like for
instance uh somebody sent me a copy of
one of my books in uh from Iran recently
and I emailed my agent and I said oh I
didn't know we did like a Persian
translation and he said we didn't he
said Iran doesn't recognize uh copyright
they just do whatever they want he's
like you'll never see a penny from these
books so the point is like if uh if you
sell a million books in Russia right
you're not getting your standard royalty
rate you may never see a penny of that
you might get an initial advance but
you'll you know it's you start to get
into uh let's say less transparency in
the accounting as you sell so you can't
you can't simply go well what's the
total number of copies sold by a person
and then times that by a number you're
probably going to be overstating the
cash they have on hand so you've sold
100 million in books so then like the
estimate based off of the numbers you
said would be like around 13 14 15 take
home I mean how many authors are doing
that selling five million books very
very few I mean definitely there are a
lot there are lots of people who have
done it and there are people who have
done much much higher than that but like
as far as people who write about
philosophy I mean I'm not sure it's been
done ever uh certainly not in in in like
the modern world so you know when I went
to my publisher and I you know uh
offered them an obscure book about
ancient philosophy in 2011 2012 for for
the stock but the first joke book you
know they offered me my Advance on the
obstacles away was 75 000 they were not
they were not thinking you know that
series would sell three or four million
copies do you think that your life has
or will become so we were talking about
Tim Ferriss and we're like you know
however much he's made on books it
probably pales in comparison he's
arguably like just guessing maybe he's
worth 150 to 250 million dollars based
off of his Shopify and Uber and Seed
Investments and who he probably has done
so many more things that I don't even
know about do you think that your
business is going to be a similar thing
where it's almost like the books are
awesome but they're going to be tiny
compared to the other uh revenue streams
I don't know I don't I don't do that
many Investments but it is weird like I
I
um
I was an advisor early on to like
butcherbox and they've done a few sort
of private transactions that I took part
in and it is both humbling and surreal
to be like to get a check and be like
I would have had to sell a lot of
books to get this same amount of money
and this amount of money was you know a
lot less work so I think for someone
like Tim you know when when you can when
you can invest in something that scales
at that level it I I do think it makes
you a little disinterested in the
economics of publishing even though they
are quite they are quite good I yeah I
mean I was like and everyone talks about
in writing a book and they say I think
he's the one who told me this he's like
it sucks he's like it just it stinks he
he says he goes I love it kind of but I
also really hate it it's very
uncomfortable and it's a lot of hard
work and I was like yeah I don't know
why you'd write a book then when you if
if you don't have if you don't if you
don't truly truly love it I have no idea
if he does or does not but it's very
hard it seems it's almost impossible it
is super weird though because uh like a
lot wealthy people read books right
there the the the interesting thing
about books is that they sort of punch
above their weight culturally it's like
the Opera or something right and so uh
like you could be very famous on YouTube
and your average billionaire might not
know who you are but if you write like a
business book uh or a political book
that sells reasonably well you're gonna
you're gonna have some name recognition
in an elite group and so I've gotten to
meet like a number of very successful
business people over the years and like
as a rule they all want to write books
or all want to talk about whether they
should write a book or not and it was
actually very helpful for me to learn
that early on because like every author
I knew was trying to start a business or
follow in Tim ferriss's footsteps and
invest in these companies to get really
really rich and then I would meet really
really rich people and they wanted to
write books and it was a reminder to me
that like
uh doing stuff that's cool that you like
that means something to you is what
people do with their money when they
have it and so they're like like I met
this guy uh you actually probably know
him but I won't put him on the spot but
anyways he'd written a couple books and
then he started a VC uh company uh he
raised a fund he raised like a hundred
million dollars and uh she had to put
writing on the side to raise this fund
and I asked him you know um like why are
you doing this like what are you gonna I
was like let's say you really succeed
like let's say your fund crashes and you
walk away with like 20 million dollars
um what would you do with it right and
he was like he's like do you know who
Elan de baton is he's an author who's
started this company called School of
Life uh he was like I think I would do
something like that and I was just I
just burst into laughter because like
let's do it now was it yeah he was it's
like that that story about the you know
the fisherman uh who meets that Western
businessman who tells him like you know
if you really scale up your company
you know one day you can sit on a beach
somewhere and it's like that's what I do
now and so there is kind of this
weirdness where people think
Financial Freedom is this kind of
abstract good and then you meet people
who have it and they still have to wake
up and figure out what they're gonna do
all day
dude I listen to your I want to talk
about the YouTube thing in a second but
I listen to your YouTube videos every
single morning when I take a walk and
like it makes me feel so good about
myself not maybe not good about myself
but I feel like I'm getting so much from
it whether it's education whether it's
just like you're helping me think
differently I don't know what it is but
I get so much from it when you you're
the one creating all this stuff or at
least you're paraphrasing like
interesting people do you think that you
are absorbing these lessons better than
most others like you know like are you
you just told this very simple story of
like well why would you go and do this
this and this when you're already doing
that now are you motivated by like are
you motivated by money are you motivated
by all these things that you talk about
like look this in this and this may not
make you happy
I think uh I I certainly struggle with
it like every you know single person
does because it's not like just knowing
it doesn't magically make it easy but I
would say like like a big lesson like
that like why are you trying to make all
this money to get somewhere you're
already you already could be I feel like
I do a better job learning those those
big philosophical lessons like sort of
where do you Reign ambition in you know
sort of how do you define meaning or
happiness or contentment in your life I
probably am better at that than I am at
some of the more basic stuff like you
don't have to be anxious about this or
like why are you letting this person get
under your skin or why are you losing
their temper about X Y or Z so like I
feel like the bigger stuff the the
stoicism or the philosophy sort of uh
connects with me and and by the way that
story that about the fishermen actually
traces back to like the 14th century
about uh it's his story about a prince
uh advising a king or an advisor
advising of Prince so the story goes way
back I feel like I get that better than
I do stuff that might be seem really
easy for most people which is just like
you know sort of day-to-day emotional
management
how you said something really cool on
the I was listening to this the other
day there's two things that stuck out
but the first one is with Matthew
McConaughey you're talking about content
and you're asking him about how what he
chooses like which projects he chooses
and apparently he there was the whole
part of the episode was talking about
how he had like 10 or 20 million dollar
offer and he was like nah I don't want
to do this this doesn't this doesn't
speak to me this is not how I want to
spend my time and he was like he felt
guilt over that and you guys were
talking about Bob Dylan and I think it
was you who said I want to make content
like Bob Dylan which is quality and
quantity don't necessarily have to be at
odds with each other like I can output
lots of really cool great stuff and you
do do that and the daily stoic is an
email then you have the daily dad
another email and then you have the
books which is you have dozens of them
or a dozen of them plus and then you
have uh the podcast and then you have
the YouTube channel and I'm like how on
Earth are you how are you outputting all
this stuff it's always awesome I love
all your well thank you I'm mean I
I think I actually like I actually like
doing it right so there's there's some
people who they don't like doing it and
so to do it because you think it'll make
money or it's what you have to do
um that would be not a reason to do it
but like I like this morning I I got up
and I wrote and yesterday when the book
came out I was excited not to come into
the office to see how you know the the
discipline did but like I had saved like
a really good chapter uh for what is the
sequel because I'm doing this four book
series like I was just pumped to
do that like that that's really what
gets me excited is doing the stuff so
I've always I I think I tend to have
uh uh more energy to make stuff than
there actually is like pipes to put
stuff out that's just like how it shook
out
um
and I I agree like I I agree with the
sentiment re Bob Dylan and that that
like quantity and quality don't have to
be opposed to each other and in fact uh
the more you do chances are you'll
you'll sort of
get something magical or important I
mean like I I really admire people who
are wired differently and they are sort
of painstakingly uh put uh you know put
lots of years into something although
like if you
um you know I bet if you asked Mark uh
he would and actually I have asked him
but like following up a massive massive
hit is really hard and I've been lucky
in that my books have done well but they
haven't done so well that like my whole
world's changed like when the obstacle
is the way it came out so obstacles the
way it came out they didn't offer me
very much money it sold well at first
but it it took
yeah and and not even slow but just
steady like it probably didn't cross the
one million copies sold Mark I know
across the hundred thousand copies Mark
within the first year because there was
a bonus attached to it so it took you
know 12 months to sell a hundred
thousand copies but it probably took an
additional four
to five years before it crossed the 1
million copy Mark so like for someone
like Mark or James clear or other other
people like it would they they hit the 1
million Mark in like a number of months
and when you start to do that everything
changes expectations change uh you know
inbound inquiries change
um and I think I think it becomes hard
to just like do the thing so I I feel
like kind of lucky to be like to have a
niche but to to have a big Niche but for
it still to very much be a niche right
like uh there's just more people haven't
heard of me than have heard of me and
that is a nice place to operate in
dude so many people so the hustle we
were a daily email and then me and Sean
do this thing three days a week and
people are like hey how are you doing
quantity I want to get started but like
you know I'm like banking 21 episodes
before I start or I'm like perfecting
like this blog post and you know I'm
going more for quality versus quantity
and in my head or sometimes I'll tell
them I'm like no that's a false
dichotomy that's not true like the
quality is the quantity uh like you know
you like the the output here or like the
If This Were uh like quality plus
quantity equals it would be like uh you
know like the total reach and how
impactful they are and the types of
people you're impacting and to do that
you have to have like something in there
for quantity and it's really just kind
of an excuse to procrastinate further
that you're making up for yourself but
hey it gets easier as you get into it's
Unique quantity you need the swings to
get better and B if you treat it like a
job you could have way more output than
you think
yeah I have a couple thoughts there so
one it's like try to apply that logic to
like any other thing like imagine if you
met a comedian and they were like I'm
really focused on quality instead of
quantity so I don't do a lot of stage
time like I just don't go up very often
you'd be like you're a shitty stand-up
comic like the way you get good at it is
by doing it a lot right and it's very
hard to get to Quality without years of
uh back and forth with an audience right
like it's just really hard and so
especially online where you're giving
the thing away for free like you should
be focused on quantity because quantity
is how you get to a place where what you
do is worth paying for at a premium
level like with a book or something so I
like I I've done a free email every day
for six years right
um that that's built a business but are
you writing that I read it every day I
mean every once in a while like like
let's say 10 of them are you know hey
I'll work with someone on my team be
like hey I already wrote about this can
you work this into a draft for me to
approve or rewrite but like the vast
majority of those daily emails were like
a hundred percent original ideas that I
put out a hundred percent of the dads
that make it easier both both
you're writing both of those every day
yeah well I don't write it I mean I
write every day but I don't write the
email every day right so like I'm
currently let's say like I could pull
this up let me I have a document
um where I I have someone track them
like I am I'm scheduled out on daily
stoic through and daily dad through
October 14th and then I have 10 written
that are ready to record 16 that are
recorded but not unscheduled and then
nine on daily dad that are ready to
record and eight that are recorded but
not scheduled so like and that's your
system yeah so I'm just do like I might
sit down today like I have I don't know
where my to-do list is but on my to-do
list I have three sort of one sentence
ideas for daily dad emails and I might
bust that out in 30 minutes and then
that's you know almost a week worth of
content right there
are you uh writing the scripts to your
YouTube videos I think you're only doing
one or two a week right
yes uh so YouTube uh I have a I have a I
have a actually wait let me I'll come
back to that in a sec the other thing I
would say about the people who are like
oh I really want to get to Quality
that's why I take so long when I look at
what those people make I very rarely see
the quality right like they're like oh
you know what this book it took me five
years and I'm like where show me five
years of work in this thing right I'm
I'm not arguing with you that it it
transpired over five years but I don't
think you showed up and worked on this
as you said like a job every day for
five years I think it either it because
if that were true I think it would
either be a lot better or I think it
would have come out a lot faster right
so I think a lot of people are baking in
a lot of inefficiencies and a lot of uh
procrastination inside that and then
patting themselves on the back and
saying that they're doing a thing that
they're really focused on quality so
that's just like a dispute I have I
think a lot of people take way too long
to do things
um
when when I see like a Robert Greene or
Robert Carro or you know one of these
greats I'm like I see the I see the five
years like it's obvious like you were
like Robert Greene was telling me the
other day he's like seven months into a
chapter on this book that he's writing
right now and when I read that chapter
I'll see every day right because
like that he's not lying dude when I
read Robert Greene and um the uh what's
his uh what's Carol's book Moses um yeah
the Robert Moses book Robert Moses and
then I just got done reading the rise of
the Third Reich which is like which is
like a 1500 or 1300 word like epic and
then it pretty much like Titan is like
this too anything Ron chernow does yes
every sentence ha like to me it's like a
life's work and if they're lucky they
can maybe get three of them yes and I
read those things and they make me
depressed because I just think like I I
can never do anything this detailed
oriented this beautiful like it it those
history it's I think it's mostly history
books every single sentence is amazing
and I don't understand how you could do
that for so long yeah this is the
William Manchester series on Churchill
which I would highly recommend this is
the Taylor Branch series on Martin
Luther King also incredible in the
acknowledgments of the last book in uh
the the King series Taylor Branch talks
about how his youngest son was born like
the day he started the series and then
took a break from college to help him
finish the last book that's crazy man
this is so nuts those are really like
life's work they are and it's not just
that every sentence is perfect but like
we don't see that if you think about the
iceberg we don't see the research the
interviews right the on like location
observing that went into forming one of
those those sentences so yeah like
there's definitely people who there's a
reason they only do two or three things
in their lifetime and then there's
everybody else and chances are like
you're everybody else uh and so uh
there's that and then as far as the
YouTube videos go I do a couple
different ones like uh one the I think
the easiest YouTube videos we do are
like compilations of like reels or
Instagram clips that I do so there's not
a lot of script there it's just the
intro it's like piecing together sort of
uh meditations on a larger idea but if
it is a like you know how to read Marcus
Aurelius how to read Seneca
um or you know let me tell you the
biography of this stoic or
I have one coming out next week that's
about the relationship between Marcus
Aurelius and antoninus Pius his
stepfather that's a combination between
like having somebody give me an outline
and then me usually drawing on something
that I wrote somewhere else so for me
the writing particularly of the books is
what generates the vast majority of the
content and then I have people who help
me just just in the way that I don't do
the Spanish edition of my books I have
people who help translate what I've done
into different mediums are you using
Google Docs yeah for them for the most
part yeah and how big is the team uh
like 10 people now probably yeah that
includes the bookstore
and also Does it include daily stoic and
uh uh a daily Dad yeah yeah I'm saying
that I probably have 10 employees maybe
maybe 11 or 12 but but
less than 15. dude that is crazy man the
output is just awesome I I think that's
amazing
[Music]
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better I was
messaging you the other day because
um
someone was like hey you should start a
book club to me and I'm like well I read
a lot but like you Ryan should really
start it like someone like that and I
looked a while ago I looked in the book
of the month business the book it's
called book of the month and it's like a
company that's been around for like 50
60 maybe even 100 years it's been around
for a long time and it's traded hands a
ton I think right now last I heard
they're in the 70 million range of
Revenue
um which is a big business but I don't
know if it's growing and I don't know if
that makes a profit I don't know what
the situation is but have you looked
into these book of the month businesses
I think Reese Witherspoon had one too
that I think was profitable yeah there's
a there's a couple different ones
there's another company called Literati
uh book of the month the book of the
month concept definitely goes back uh
quite a bit and that used to be like a
way that you would guarantee a book
success would be if you were selected to
one of those clubs because they might
buy a hundred thousand copies or
something
um
there's and then there's uh what is it
called the next big idea book club uh
which I think Malcolm Gladwell is an
investor in there's there's a there's a
handful of them
um the problem with the business is
first off not that many people read
right uh unfortunately
um second uh the logistics of it are
what is tough right so like at the very
best you're gonna be able to get those
books from like let's say you're doing
physical right at the very very best
you're going to be able to get those
books at 50 off from the publisher so if
you start to get into uh
you know like
it it drives the subscription like
already your subscription is more than
Netflix which gets you unlimited of the
best most entertaining content in the
world right so the the really tough part
is get into a place where you can move a
lot of books and the revenue is high so
I I started this newsletter like 15
years ago where I just recommend books
uh what do you have like 250 000 people
now on it something like that yeah and
and I just prefer to like look if you
want to buy the book from my bookstore I
make a little bit of money doing that if
you buy it from Amazon I get the
commission but I'd much rather just have
that list in that audience than try to
monetize a book club itself because the
bundle of including the book plus
fulfilling the book Plus customer
service and all that other stuff it I
think I think it's just hard to make the
business itself work how much revenue
can you make on one send
uh from from the reading list newsletter
I don't know
um I don't know uh uh I actually 10 or
20 grand maybe yeah that would be that
would be a lot uh because the the other
thing that I found is that the people
who read the most uh who like real like
like the kind or at least the kind of
readers that I attract are like I don't
want to say they're lone wolves but
they're more like uh like I don't know
about you but like the way I read is I
just have at all times a long list of
like books I'm going to get around to
reading I'm not like oh you're reading
this book right now I have space for you
in my life so like like if I think about
the impact that the list has had as far
as moving copies for books it's not like
oh we sold this many copies of this book
this month it's more over a Time
although I did invest in this company do
you know the company vinyl me I think I
introduce you to them Matt Fiedler the
founder is mine that was my high school
he was my or my cup my very very very
close college friend and for those
listening finally pleases awesome I
don't know how many I don't remember how
many people they have 20 30 000
subscribers and they send out a record a
vinyl of a piece of vinyl and I remember
he was uh like complaining to me he was
like man the the like we whenever
someone gets selected for our vinyl uh
like when we pick an album it becomes
the best-selling vinyl in the country
because we're the biggest but but now
they're not counting it anymore and uh
right it's the same thing we're talking
about with the best seller list they
they would be the number one vinyl album
in the country each month but but they
just get skunked from the Billboard
charts yeah and I I haven't asked Matt
about the business lately but it's been
around for 10 years now and it seems to
be doing good I I
but that's a different experience right
and so I I'm one I was I guess I'm an
advisor so I got some early shares in
vital me when it came out so and that's
been a surprisingly big business like I
I when I see the numbers I'm always like
whoa that's bigger than I would have
guessed right you wouldn't you'd think
like oh maybe a thousand people a month
not 20 000 people a month yeah that's a
lot of people but but I think and music
is people consume more music than they
do books right and you can do it over
and over again with a bunch of people
it's a passive experience and the the
art of Discovery is different right like
you want to be suggested random things
on a regular basis and I think with a
book like people have so little room to
read in their lives that I I don't know
I just I I
I like the idea of the business and it
would be amazing to make it work I have
struggled to actually see it work and I
think uh there's probably just
ultimately better ways to monetize that
attention than uh then then a list of
subscribers you have to service each
month for a specific kind of book you
said something earlier about like you
get access to all these amazing people
and I follow you on Instagram and I've
talked to you a bit and I follow your
content and you are hanging out with
like all these athletes you're hanging
out with billionaires and business
people and celebrities and all these
interesting people who are some of the
people who you've met where you said I
want to emulate this particular
attribute or the way that they've done
this this and this I admire so much or
this person is just wildly impressive
who do you admire or uh of all the
people you've met oh that's a good
question
um you know I actually talk about this
in the in the end of uh of discipline uh
as I was sort of struggling with the
book kind of early in the process like
one I was just tired because
I've done a lot of books in a very short
amount of time and like the idea it just
I don't know it just wasn't gelling and
um I had lunch with uh with Manu
Ginobili uh who just got inducted in the
Hall of Fame uh this month
um and we were having lunch at the at
the bookstore he he'd come out and we
were hanging out and it just sort of
struck me
like this dude has four rings like his
four championship rings and he has two
gold medals uh and is a Hall of Famer
and he was like I don't want to say he's
a regular person because that sounds
like uh that almost minimizes it but the
point is when you think about someone
who has four rings I think you think
more of like a Jordan character who is
fundamentally out of balance right like
so there's no disputing Jordan is Jordan
is like one of the greats if not the
greatest like basketball player maybe
athlete as a as a whole right
um but but we tend to think that that to
be that good
requires like
fundamentally some fundamental
trade-offs about what kind of person you
are and what your day-to-day life looks
like like
um
Tom Brady right uh Comes Back to
Football he can't walk away and it may
well cost him his marriage right and and
people see that and they go that's what
it takes right
um
I'm not sure that that is what it takes
that might be you know what it took in
that specific scenario but like I the
more I meet really successful people I
become less impressed by like how much
money they've made or like you know
whether they have the most rings or the
second most rings or whatever it is and
I go like
um
is this person like a good parent do
they seem like they live in reality you
know
um or or are they like are they actually
able to wake up and enjoy like what they
have today or is it like they're
traveling here and there and they're
just always doing stuff right
um I I think like to me what the the the
journey that I've tried to go on
inspired by people like that is
I want to be world class at what I do
and and like be a somewhat of a normal
person like who else it's almost easier
to be great than it is to be good if
that makes sense yeah that's awesome who
who else have you uh who have you met so
I you know him and Chris Bosh are
interesting I've I listened to a bunch
of content that you made with those guys
I felt the same way about Chris Bosh
when I was listening to him I'm like oh
man this dude's like kinda yeah maybe
normal's insulting but like that's what
I was like you're I'm never gonna be
seven feet tall but like you know like
your mentality is achievable
you know what I mean
it's kind of funny as CR I do feel the
same way about Chris uh and and his wife
and and my wife and friends
um but like uh
every once in a while I'll mention one
one of them to the other and then I
forget that they it Chris said something
to me actually when I had him on the
daily Stoke podcast he's like you know
he's elbowed me in the face like a lot
like like it was like realizing like
like their best and worst moments came
like the the moment in both of their
careers
came at each other's expense right like
like uh Manu goes up for a rebound that
that Chris gets that Chris tips back to
Ray Allen who makes a three-pointer to
win to basically win the series right
like it is also weird to think like yeah
here are these like kind of two people
that I admire and then they're on like
uh their careers were like on a
collision course with each other are
they buddies now I don't think so no I
don't think so even though they like
they live not far from each other right
the ones in San Antonio one's in Austin
and I I do not think that they uh see
each other socially now it might take
some time like maybe maybe in 20 years
uh the that rivalry Fades away is there
anyone else who you've met and you're
like man the way that you're pulling
this off or the way that you're playing
life I just admire so much
well you know it was I had a weird one a
couple weeks ago I I um I don't want to
say who it is not because I it I feel
weird uh dropping the name but anyways
let's just say I met this musician and
uh he'd read the books and he reached
out to me through someone we know and he
was like Hey you know next time you're
in New York uh you should come see me or
let me know I'd love to have dinner with
you so I was like hey I'm actually going
to be in New York like next week and
he's like oh all right my assistant will
like send you the details and um the
details were uh like go to this helipad
and then the helicopter took me uh and
his son and uh our mutual friend to
their house in the Hamptons where we had
dinner and then it flew us back to
Manhattan after dinner uh what yeah it
was nuts uh it was super nuts
but like talking to this person
um he was like I was like so what's
going on with you and he's like well you
know my youngest just went away to
college so we're empty nesters like
we're gonna spend an extra couple weeks
here in the Hamptons and it was like
um
again I think at the end of your life
and when you reflect on whether you were
successful or not you're going to think
like what is do my kids want to spend
time with me or not like am I what am I
on my fourth marriage or am I my first
marriage and he's he's been he's still
with his high school sweetheart right
despite selling a hundred million albums
in between meeting and like the day that
I was there he has a business that he
founded with his son like I I like to me
when I see stuff like that I'm like okay
this is fundamentally not normal and
that like we just flew on a helicopter
to have dinner and that was like
you know like a wave of the hand for you
but that fundamentally you still worked
very hard to remain rooted in some
semblance of normalcy where your kids
are not monsters and uh you're you like
spending time together
you uh one of my favorite books is
conspiracy which is uh Nick Deton I
believe is that his name Nick Denton
yeah yeah Nick Denton the founder of
Gawker and Peter Thiel and there's just
so many moments in that book where I've
been like oh my God I cannot believe
that that's true and basically like the
fact that like Peter Thiel plotted and
had people on staff for like some amount
of years five or ten years like a long
time in order to like hey when you see
Gawker screw up you tell me and we're
gonna pounce and we're gonna sue them
because they outed me out as being gay
or you also told another story about how
Peter Thiel had a Mercedes uh a black
Mercedes everywhere he went that was
just ready to roll in case anything bad
happened and I don't know if this was in
the book or if I'm making this up but
I'm almost positive there was like a
plane to New Zealand that like you he
knew about or something like that is
that true or am I making that up the
Mercedes thing is in the book The New
Zealand plane thing that sounds true uh
but it that I think his New Zealand
citizenship came after I finished the
book yeah just like all this crazy stuff
what um sure what was it like uh getting
to know that guy I mean he he's one of
those guys where like I actually don't
think there is I don't know him but
where there actually is no balance and
he is just really quirky
well I think uh it's it's both it's both
very understandable and then very
inexplicable right like if you had made
billions of dollars and you were very
powerful
I don't think you would like to be
picked on right like I think people were
like why would he do this and it's like
this this bully came along and
humiliated him in his eyes like I I
don't like not being a gay man I I can't
really
fully understand what what the reaction
would be to being outed and and the a
number of people that I that I
interviewed for the book who were gay
like they didn't even understand so like
let's just let's just stipulate that
his explanation of his experience was
that this was humiliating and he uh
found it to be very frustrating uh
I think when you're at that level one of
the feelings that you don't sit that
doesn't sit well with you is impotence
right like so when people were like
Peter there's just nothing you can do
about it he was like then what the
is the point of everything I've done
right and so so in that sense I think
it's very understandable I think that
the problem is if you're the kind of
person who it's like I'm gonna spend 10
years uh chasing down this media Outlet
when everyone is telling me not to do
that you're also the kind of person
who can get sucked into other things
that I think are going to pay off less
well whether it's backing JD Vance or
Blake Masters or some of the other
political bets that he's made
um you know I I find this sort of anger
and the resentment of what it seems to
be driving that I've I have trouble
I have trouble understanding it
dude I don't have trouble understanding
that I get so I I don't it comes from a
at least for me like I would have done
the same thing if I if like if you're if
you have that money in power and someone
wrongs you I wanna I I have that same
mentality when I'm like I want to crush
them typically I've got my wife saying
like dude chill you're this isn't worth
it and so like I listen to her but if I
didn't have her I'd be like no no we're
gonna let's destroy them and it comes
with that I get that that I understand
that's The Count of Monte Cristo that's
the oldest Revenge story of of History
I'm saying more the other thing like the
problem is uh when you sort of start to
feel like you can bend the world to your
will that you can do anything and
everything I think you get sucked down
other avenues and I think some of the
political bets he's made uh you know
even even Trump himself like the fact
that it worked uh doesn't mean that it
made rational sense but how do you not
feel like that I mean with my very very
small amount of internet Fame and my
mediocre to small financial success I'm
like oh like I just I bent you know in
in a I'm a big fish sometimes in a small
pond and I'm a small fish in a big pond
but I'll be like oh sick I just I bent
though that's I say it all the time I
bent the world to my reality like I just
made my my true the thing I want to be
true I made it true and that is
incredibly intoxicating I think that
there's lots of ways to do that there's
a lot if you wrote a book and millions
of people read it there's a way to do
that if you become powerful in politics
there's a way to do that if view the
easiest and most practical way for most
people is if you learn how to make money
on your own then you're like oh like
whatever I want I turn into reality I
have a joke I call myself a manifest
Cowboy like I just make I make the
things that I want the things I think of
I am not a business person I am an
expert at making things that I think of
be real and even at a small scale I get
intoxicated like that and by I get
Intoxicated by it do not I I've seen up
close I I feel like very lucky that up
close and personal multiple times
particularly early on in my career I saw
people who who had the ability to do
that
um also destroy themselves right so like
I I Dr Doug Charney was my direct boss
right like he would call me five times a
day and I watched a guy who built a
multi-billion dollar company that made
50 million t-shirts a year uh
you know
start something I mean I didn't start it
but I let let's put it this way the The
Arc of the entrepreneurial Journey the
the Beauty and the danger of it is that
you have an idea for something that is
insane right like people are like that
will never work here's all the reasons
you will fail do not do that you will
regret it right and then you do it and
it works right that's that's the
definition of what entrepreneurship does
if everyone knew how to do it or if it
was easy it would have already been done
you were able to create something from
nothing I you know that violates
everyone else's conception of what's
possible the dangerous thing you take
from that is you now as you said see
yourself as a person who does that and
you see people who tell you that you
can't do it or shouldn't do it or
criticize you for doing it you see them
as the enemy right so when Doug Turner
is like I'm gonna start a made in USA
Sweatshop free fashion company company
that doesn't print its brand on things
doesn't use professional models and owns
all of its own stores and I'm gonna sell
all those products for an enormous
premium like that's that's nuts
right like no part of that should work
so then he does it and then people are
like okay you did it but you should
really have seasoned operators around
you you know you really shouldn't over
expand too quickly you know by the way
it's not proper to have sexual relations
with your employees right all these
things that they told him he was like
you who are you to tell me look at
what I've done right and so he crashes
and burns as a result of this exactly
what you said like I'm a manifest Cowboy
the rules don't apply to me I can bend
reality to my will like do you ever you
ever heard that expression the political
expression about the reality-based
community do you know that no no what's
that so so as as George as George Bush
was contemplating the invasion of Iraq I
think it was Karl Rove but I one of one
of the officials in the Bush
Administration you know is responding to
all the people who are like it's going
to be an enormous Quagmire you're not
going to get the like right now you have
no international support Bob it's gonna
cost this you know and they go look he's
like there's two kinds of people he's
like there's the people who live in the
reality-based community and then the
people who believe in America it
basically says who believe in American
exceptionalism who believes that America
creates his own creates its own reality
bends the rules the order of the world
to its will and so they believed as they
went into Iraq that yeah it was a bad
idea for all these reasons but that
could be changed through force of will
and confidence and Firepower Etc but
they're not always wrong but but it's
not true maybe in that case but like
that that feeling is cousins to uh
cousins to the other working do you know
what I mean where's Ginobili from
uh Argentina like this Argentinian dude
is Gonna Come and like be the boss and
like kill it and like you know what I
mean like that they're they're cousins
yes but but here's the thing like when
you look at manu's story he did not wake
up one day in Argentina and go I will be
a Hall of Fame NBA player right he makes
his way like almost all those Journeys
are much smaller and humbler than that
right he makes the Argentinian team uh
he's pretty good he gets you know he
gets an opportunity to play in Europe
where he plays he gets drafted like very
late a total surprise he had not
actually even entered the draft he was
just drafted by the Spurs who let him
play in Europe for like three years
before he comes over almost nobody
believed in him I mean he knew what he
he knew he was good and he was confident
in his abilities but there was not these
delusions of great he was not Kanye West
going around saying I'm Steve Jobs right
like this was he he was like uh in the
Churchill book they talk about this
Churchill did not
at the uh when when Britain is standing
alone
uh he does not in he does not know for
certain that he will be able to bring
America into the war and that you're
like what what what what Churchill does
is he buys some time right like all of
these things start small and they build
they're when when the person has this
Vision that they can clearly articulate
that they know to be like that to me
that leads to disaster more often than
the prophecy comes true
dude that's crazy fascinating to me I
gotta keep thinking about that but um
another thing that you're associated
with that I find like equally impressive
even though it's much smaller now to all
the other things that you've done is the
ghost town Cerro Gordo which I'm a very
very very small investor in but the
reason why it's awesome is no you're not
a small investor you're the guy uh the
reason why
well you're you're you're I I view you
Brent and Nathan uh Nathan Berry as like
uh you know the the guys but so
basically like in 2015 or 14 you guys
like you know got some money together
and you bought this town that went viral
because it was like you can buy a whole
town for 1.3 million dollars a ghost
town and you guys bought it and it was
like doing okay whatever and then the
pandemic hit and Brent spin UPS this
YouTube channel and it felt like in a
matter of six months it got a million
subscribers and I remember being in my
apartment in San Francisco miserable
that I'm trapped in this place and I see
these videos of him and it's like the it
felt like it got me through the first
like 12 months of the pandemic watching
those videos like I felt so much better
watching these like 20 or 30 minute
videos of this charming cute dude named
Brent like saying like hey so here's
this old mine that I just found in my
town let's just like you know walk a
hundred feet into this mine and let's
just see what we find and it's when you
think of a mind you think of like a cave
and this was like a like a crawl space
and he just like is going deep in these
places and that was amazing what what uh
what's your feeling on how everything's
going with that and like what's the plan
well I mean 100 feet into mine one of
the minds is 9 900 feet straight down
that he regularly goes in it's
insane it's crazy his videos are so good
did you advise him or you guys were
Partners on something does he did he get
the content bug from you are you
advising him how is this it's so good
it's an amazing story it actually goes
to what we were just talking about like
the idea in it as an outsider or in
retrospect it feels like guy makes
brilliant investment buys Town turns it
into a YouTube channel makes these
amazing videos in this and it seems
obvious now blows up yeah
um
but that's not how it went at all right
like first time by the way what's the
name of the channel uh Ghost Town living
okay uh when when he first told me about
it I was like dude that's a horrible
idea I'm not interested at all right
like I came in at a very small level at
first because I didn't think it was a
good idea but Brent's idea was buy this
place find build a hotel on the site and
make it some sort of like luxury resort
thing that that they failed to do for
like two years maybe even three years he
had no intention of living up there it
was losing money hand over fist right
like he how many acres is it it's 300
acres but it backs up to like thousands
of Acres of government land so it's and
it's like in the mountains like four
hours outside of L.A it's yeah it's
about three and a half hours from La it
it looks down uh on Death Valley at
about 8 500 uh feet it was once the
largest silver mine in the United States
but there's like no water and
electricity right there I was just up
there he he like I took a nice warm
shower there's water now
oh but there wasn't I guess is what I
mean there was not I mean historically
there were some Springs and then those
dried up and I mean it has always been a
battle of the elements but it's funny
that you you you bring up how you liked
the videos during the pandemic my
four-year-old fell in love with the
videos during the pandemic and that's
part of the reason I end up investing
more money in it was that my son is
obsessed uh like he knows he had trouble
so Brent started as my intern like 12 or
13 years ago I think
um and my son is met I mean is known
Brent his whole life and it he's got so
enthralled with the videos that he had
trouble because it was the pandemic we
couldn't see him he had trouble like
conceiving of the fact that this was a
real person that he knew that this was
different than the YouTube channels of
other people that he watches that he
doesn't know and so
he's so Charming in these videos and
he's so endearing and like I don't know
I've not really hung out with him I've
only chatted with him a couple times it
seems like he just kind of turned on
this charm and Charisma and it was like
intoxicating he's always been like a
behind the scenes person and and I think
that's what's so interesting is like
yeah he didn't just randomly start a
YouTube channel one day like he started
the daily Stoke YouTube channel and he
started the daily stroke podcast like he
he was the one who who built out the
systems or created the universes for me
um and then that I am obviously the face
of but he was the one who was like here
I think we should do this and he's the
one that figured like you know we
probably had a hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers when he went to Cerro Gordo
so he had experience that he'd learned
on the job so to speak uh working with
me
um and then the funny thing is uh we had
shot some videos for daily stoic like
the first week of March 2020 or maybe
the last week of February
um and he had taken the camera home to
like upload some stuff and so when he
went to Sarah Gordo he just took my
camera or our camera like that Sarah
Gordo was started with equipment that he
had got for daily stoic and then used
skills that he had developed uh with
daily stoic that ultimately blew up into
this thing that I don't think he
definitely not I would have predicted
but like people often underestimate how
long you have to spend developing like a
Baseline kind of skills before you know
sort of the man meets the moment so to
speak dude I read that in in Mastery
Mastery changed my life I remember like
exactly where I was where I read it and
I was like oh this this is called
apprenticeship like and that it totally
Mastery you know I got turned on to you
because I was or maybe I don't remember
if you got me onto green or him to you
but I remember reading Mastery and that
was like a life-changing book because it
talked talked about that but um Sarah
Gordon you ever think about that like do
you ever think about the fact that the
hustle and this podcast could actually
be the apprenticeship for like a company
you start in your 50s that's 10 oh it's
going to be it's going to be and people
like
yo all right so the hustle we sold for
let's say tens of millions of dollars
which is like I think by most people if
you do I think I was 31 30 when we sold
it which so like that's six that I would
say it's objectively successful but
compared to others like it's nothing
right like sure compared to the company
that bought us it's nothing yeah you
know they bought us but uh and so a lot
of people were like well you know like
you guys only did that in four years I'm
like yeah we did it in four years I also
spent four years before that though uh
studying writing and like blogging and
reading and like being a student and I
learned a skill which my skill was
copywriting and that skill led me to
this other thing which led me to this
other thing which led me to this other
thing and I often tell people I'm like
everyone says overnight successes aren't
true and I'm like well in a sense
actually they can be like you could be a
Mark Manson or something and like write
a book and like it get really big really
fast but it more likely than not that
could happen like hitting a lottery is
real like look at Instagram but learning
the skill for five or ten years in
advance is often necessary
yeah to give Mark Credit though Mark
doesn't hit the lottery I mean Mark was
an online copywriter and marketer and
had a platform for a decade before he
writes a book right right but what I
mean is like the set functions and
growth are real yeah you know like it
could be like it's doing okay it's going
okay it's going okay and then a matter
of like a month or three months it's
like boom something just changed like
that is real and I think people actually
don't like acknowledging that because
the story of like slow and steady is
preferred because that like there's more
character to that but like
a step functions exist but you have to
work a certain amount of time typically
in order to get that step function
that's what I mean you know I think
about Michael Lewis in that regard like
Michael Lewis is is a fantastic writer
he's been a great writer for 40 years he
wrote liars poker which is about Finance
he wrote The Blind Side you know he
wrote a number of these books that were
that were big and he was he was a
leading non-fiction author and then 2008
happens
and it's the most inexplicable but
widespread financial event of you know
since the Great Depression and he is
uniquely suited to write The Big Short
which was his big transformative you
know uh huge book like Moneyball The
Blind Side the other movies that come
out I believe they come out after the
big short like Michael Lewis today looks
like he's always been huge but you don't
realize his career was sort of like this
and then like this right like what like
I I think about that I I'm very proud of
all the books that I've written and I I
continue to write them and work on it
every day but I all I want to say I hold
out hope but I I feel like there's some
part of me that thinks
all of this is training for like the
book at the moment maybe it happens
maybe it doesn't maybe it's the moment
but the book only sells 10 copies but
like I do feel like it's building
towards whatever I'm meant to do are you
not satisfied with your career
now I'm very satisfied like more I was
just writing about this in my journal
this morning like when I'm look at the
sales number of this book this isn't
just like what I dreamed of this is like
10x what I even conceived of as being
possible I'm just saying like uh I I I
want what I'm working on to set me up
for like something truly challenging so
challenging that I or perfect for my
skills and what I and my world view that
I can't even think of it yet
dude consistently I've said once I hit
this wealth number I likely won't want
any more and then I always do once I uh
lift this much weight or do this type of
athletic feat that I've been really
working hard towards like I'll be happy
and then I get there I'm like but we
could go a little we could do a little
more so like uh I think that's just
unilaterally true with at least people
who are driven enough to achieve
anything interesting like it's just like
it
I've just settled with it's just never
enough I mean that's okay I've never
heard of someone getting to the number
like like like actually getting the
number because the goal posts always
move so it wouldn't always hear people
say it there's a number like when I when
I talk to an author and they're like my
goal is to sell a million copies or
whatever I go like I don't have goals
like why would you why would you even
put a ceiling on it right like why you
should just try to sell as many copies
as it's capable of selling do you have
um other than like be a good dad and be
a good person and all this stuff do you
have any professional goals for the next
five 10 or 20 years where you say like
this is what I want or any people who
you say I I want to be I want my career
to be similar to this type of person
yeah I mean so like I sold this four
book series so to do four like four
interlocking interrelated books in
ostensibly four years that that's the
that's what it it could change but like
that is like the mountain That I'm
Climbing right now because because it
was unlike the mountains that I'd done
I'd done before I don't have like a
certain number of books that I'm trying
to write or certain number of copies
that I'm trying to write but I uh I I do
there's a like I I've never written one
of those biographies that we were
talking about and there's some part of
me that
thinks about maybe doing that at some
point
um and doing it any one place anyone in
particular
I do have a person but I don't want to
say because uh someone might steal it
but but I but I but I have thought about
doing a big a big book like that and I
there's a part of me that thinks being
able to do it and not not care like
financially like if it takes five years
or takes ten years like there's a part
of me that thinks about that and I I so
I have a couple ideas like that where
I'm like that would be a cool thing to
do
um but like I I have the weird sensation
I'm sure you have this too of like
of like very much feeling like I'm play
I'm playing with house money and that's
both really fun and then it's also a
little it's like a little unmooring
because you're like I thought I was
running with everyone else and then now
I'm just like by myself am I going fast
enough am I going too fast you know did
I tell you Daddy don't want to lose it
it's like that's a weird feeling where
you're like well I have what I wanted I
thought that I'd be willing to like
spend this much to invest on my idea and
then it's like but I don't want to lose
this and that that also exists well you
you think that being successful will
make you more courageous because you are
more secure but it actually the the
rational response to having a lot is to
become more risk-averse because you know
how hard it was to get it and so there's
a tension there you know how do you how
do you continue to push yourself without
being Reckless and how do you uh protect
what you've built without being
complacent wait but you you just said
something that reminded me of the
fisherman story you started off with
which was you said like I want to write
this biography and I hope I'll be at a
place where like financially it doesn't
matter do you don't feel that you're
there already
no no I mean I feel like I'm there I
just have to get through these two books
I've or like I I'm already creatively
committed to an idea it's like um like a
director it's like hey I've already
attached to these two movies
then like I once once my plate is clear
and I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
put it off into the future I don't feel
rushed to do it I'm just saying like
when when I have a clear
play or open road in front of me I think
that's probably something I might
around with any topics that we didn't
cover that you think need to be covered
um you know what actually yeah I
mentioned it to you and text you were
like well can we talk about like how
much money your books have been I I I
what I said was I go uh how much money
have you made
how big's your dick and what's your
social system yeah no it's it's funny
like on my first books uh like obviously
books as a market are less interesting
to people than like the movie business
but like
um
uh whenever I would sell a book like the
your agent or publisher they're like
should we announce this deal like
there's trades right and sometimes like
my first book got a ton of publicity
because I was like a kid who came out of
nowhere and sold a book for a bunch of
money I was always I was like I want a
press release like I want to put this
out and then probably starting I think
it was with Stillness it might have been
after definitely with this series
I realized that there was no advantage
to doing that that
um when you start talking about what
something is sold for or how like I've
two things I thought okay so I saw this
four book deal and it was a it was a
very large deal at least for me and I
had two thoughts I said one telling
people how much money I made from it it
makes you a Target makes you weird you
know it it could it could somehow be
seen as selling out or something but
then the other part I I thought I don't
want people this is an idea that's going
to take me four plus years to get to the
end of why would I want to give people
who might be writing in the same Niche
like a heads up about what I'm doing and
so I don't think I've announced you know
when I did a podcast deal when I've sold
other projects like I I see no benefit
to putting out specific figures I only
see uh downsides to that I don't know
would you do a podcast deal with no I I
do agree with it at first you know it's
like that song um
uh if dammit feels good to be a
gangsters they they said real gang real
gangsters don't flex nuts because they
know they got them
but I used to feel that way where I'm
like yeah like when I I mean I'm still
insecure about that when I was even more
insecure I would be like yeah I need to
I'm gonna rub this into my high school
friend's face
yeah and then now I'm like I don't want
to get sued I don't want to be a Target
I don't want people to pretend because
we I get all these fake people on
Twitter or Instagram pretending to be me
or like people like threaten to sue you
and when you're not wrong at all like
now I'm like uh I don't want any of that
nonsense
yeah I did I did a podcast deal with uh
with Amazon wondering uh like maybe
three months ago
um how big is the Pod now or do you
measure it in podcast downloads or
YouTube views uh YouTube is it isn't
wasn't included in the deal so it's
separate
um but uh podcast is is fantastic like I
think we we crossed 100 million
downloads that's crazy yeah do
you should do we're getting close to
being able to do that annually like not
quite but like that to me that's that's
where the numbers are so big we're at um
our monthly downloads on the podcast our
range between 1.5 and 2 or 1.3 and 2
million and then the Pod the and then
the YouTube episode views are another
one or two million so we're in the range
of two to five on any given month and uh
our next Target I'm like how do we get
to that five to ten
sounds like you're there dude I think
YouTube is the I it's weird to say like
YouTube's the big thing because it's
been around for 15 years and it's
already huge but like uh the growth I'm
seeing on YouTube stuff especially now
even with shorts it's crazy dude people
are age and older they're like what
YouTube I'm like no dog YouTube's TV
Like it Like You Know YouTube is where
it's at and it still has so much room
you because I only watch YouTube as my
TV uh yeah it's the best well dude
you're awesome man I um I asked you like
who uh you admire and who you want to
steal from and I have like a short list
of maybe three or five people and you
are on that list uh where I just think
like we're like you know I'm a family
guy like you I don't have kids yet but
like I see you raise your family I see
you with your wife I see like you know I
also bought a a kind of like a farm
inspired by you I live in Austin most of
the year like there's so many things
that you've done where I think this
guy's nailing it and I want to steal
little bits and pieces of how he's doing
and how he's living life and I admire
your confidence your drive I mean
I'm on I'm on the the Ryan holiday train
I've been on it since uh since uh the
first book so media media confessions
well we gotta we gotta hang out when
you're back man you you and I are almost
a little bit similar when we have our
toes in like the New York world and in
the LA world but you know I lived in
Tennessee for a long time I live in
Texas just like you I like doing I like
the bougie and I like the redneck
man I like it all's so uh I'll
holler at you when I get back and I
appreciate you coming on man this is
awesome I want to see the farm uh and uh
say the book name again oh discipline is
Destiny the power of self-control as
part of the stoic virtue series the
first one is uh courage is calling where
do you make the most money where people
buy it oh if you buy it from from
dailystoke.com or my bookstore the
painted porch awesome well I appreciate
you man this is awesome thank you good
thanks
foreign
[Music]